well ladies and gentlemen
joining the show
the icon and the legend that we've been
talking about
all the way
from
los angeles california
she wants liberty
she wants less taxes
she is
jan terry welcome to the show jan
man i gave you a lot of lead time travis
oh jan you have to unmute we can't hear
you
either you're muted or kyle muted you as
a saboteur somebody has muted you hold
on jen there oh we heard you can you
hear me now oh yeah jan terry is here
and jojo
jojo what happened to denny
then he died in 2018.
oh my god
i would never have done that we are big
fans jen
um i gotta be honest your your your
catalog i i've done a deep dive on you
we just played irs i think that song is
very underrated
yeah that's for next month yes it is i
always yep
it's for april you know tax month yeah
if you ever been through a tax audit you
understand the irs oh please i i just
what i want to do is i want to pay less
taxes i hate paying the taxes i pay
well yeah i mean
um that was one of the reasons why
we fought george king george was because
of his taxes
taxes on t taxes on living taxes and
then what what happens
um
one of the presidents started to do the
taxes i don't know if it was franklin
delver wolves about or one of them
beforehand hold your audio cut out i'm
sorry for a second who who i i didn't
hear you said i'm sorry
i said it was either franklin delano
roosevelt or one of the presidents
before him that started the thing with
the income tax when did you start
putting uh your politics in your music
you know we the first song we heard
obviously was i don't want to lose you
tonight which is a love song
when did you start realizing like i have
feelings about a lot of issues that i
can incorporate into this music
well because i got uh tax audited from
the ios so
i just don't know and there has never
been a song
for ios
so i just wrote it it was like a novelty
type song now skyrockets i i is one of
my favorites uh you rocking with the
guitar in front of that uh in front of
that uh open what is that thing of water
fountain the fountain of water
yeah did you get permits for that you
just go up there and start rocking
um
the
the crew that i was with we just went
and whacked
just started walking um
i understand the go-go's did something
at that fountain years ago oh wow oh
okay because your video's all just kind
of shot on location and you don't get
permission you guys just go and you rock
well
if you can go to private public places
you usually can get away with uh public
stuff and if you don't go in with a lot
of
clue it it works
if you keep it simple and keep it down
weighted you know sure when did
when did this start for you i mean
obviously i think a lot of people
found out about you through uh
losing you
uh and it became a kind of a phenomenon
on the internet but you're such a a
prolific
musician you've put out so much material
when did this all
begin
well my great my grandfather was a
musician
and he wrote songs back when they had
tim pan ali in back in new york
and my dad played the saxophone
and um
so i tried to do the saxophone was that
when i was eight but my hands were too
small
so do you have little hands jen
yeah i've got little hands oh okay so i
um
so i um
started to play the drums
oh
jumps were easier for me than playing
the um
the sax and um
i can only play a little bit of qatar
i'm not considered a top player
now you do a lot of time um
paul mccourtney i love this space and i
finally got a base before you
you're very prolific and you also write
a lot of songs about passion and love uh
baby blues i i think it's called is one
of my favorites a great video um uh you
meet this this this handsome uh
texas guy um i guess what a cowboy hat
it's almost it has like a sensual energy
to it
um
cowboy type of a song um
the ones that were in the video were
mostly um
limo drivers and i asked them if they
wanted to be in the video and i'll buy
them beer and pizza oh wow okay i'm
smart
yeah because i noticed you got united
airlines involved in the first one you
thank you united and losing you uh you
got united airlines to sign off on it
you got like the whatever the hotel was
like you got some big people involved
the where the hotel was a lot meridian
and um
that was one of the hotels that
oprah winfrey used to use for her show
and i um never heard of her
yeah and i uh
i caught up um i caught up and talked to
wolfgang
the manager and i asked him and he said
sure because and i said oh most likely
at that time it was most likely being a
promotion type thing right and he says
yes and he asked if he could have a copy
so he
so he can promote his hope um
his hotel and i said sure and then when
united united said yes um
only in public areas you can go to i'm
like okay fine how did how did losing
you end up on the internet i mean
obviously you shot it in 1993
so you know you're a good
almost 15 years away from it
feasibly even being on youtube so how
did how did that song right first end up
on the internet
i
don't know because it was on a vhs yeah
so i had i because back then is what
they were using and i have
no idea somebody put it up there and
then they consider it the worst music
videos well let me tell you
some of some of the some of the major
record labels that have their famous
artists
and pay a lot of money have worse music
videos than mine and they pay a fortune
for their uh
videos
were people kind or unkind i mean i
don't know why they'd say it's the worst
video we enjoyed it a lot why would are
they have they been kind
um
some not some
some yes but
there
there's a lot they they
they said i sing like that
um that guy from american idol that hong
kong hong kong hong kong justin guarini
hong kong um no yeah remember back in
the milk and i know the first one
um william hung oh he was not a strong
sinner
right and and and then they said i look
like miss piggy and all kinds of stuff
so who said that
people
does it you know does it bother you
no because it's their opinion and and
the only thing is
um cypo bubbly's like to pick on people
yeah you know i will say i mean and
we've talked about on the show we've
been playing your music a lot this week
i love
that you'd
never quit that you saw this thing and
you were like okay it's gaining some
traction people are seeing it and
regardless of whether they're
being kind or not you like to make music
and you just kept putting out song after
song after song and there's a ton of
them right that have done a tremendous
amount of views
yeah have you have you listened to the
new album what's your new album called i
probably have
it it just came out it's khan's songs of
songs of hope
you're sitting on two of the songs let
me see here i have not uh
i'm i mean is it on um
there it is songs of hope yes oh yeah we
did we listened to uh denny's song and
we listened to hot dog baby yes we enjoy
hot dog baby
well yeah jojo's singing on hot dog baby
wow oh wow all right you get the whole
lot you get everyone involved
um and juggles running for president in
2024 so let's see oh good for you now
let me ask you do you still perform live
at all are you still out doing live gigs
no not really
any reason
well with that kona thing um
not too many places were taking us and
um
and
the way the industry works you really
don't make holly anything and it's you
know
out there so yeah they do kind of they
screw you over
yeah i'm waiting for my documentary to
come out in my autobiography book then
when that one comes out maybe i'll
uh jojo and i'll do a book signing tour
when do they come out
i don't know the the um
the people in chicago are the ones
making it and
it's all held up out there so i have no
idea when they're going to release it
well didn't you and i know that you
wrote a couple of children's books at
one point didn't you
i wrote um
get down goblin it's the goblin story in
rock and roll santa get down but didn't
you write books as well those are the
books oh those are all you name those oh
it goes with the songs they were adapted
the songs were adapted into stories
awesome what happened to the books and
when can we see those
the um the only thing i i've been doing
is because i couldn't get a major
publisher because the books are too
small
i've been last year i printed and
printed them up myself and then i was
selling them um
selling them that way with with the
cookbook with my microwave cookbook oh
my god microwave cookbook
i might do it again this year you know
probably
in september or october are you shipping
all the stuff yourself so you're kind of
doing everything from home
uh for the books yeah
how did you do
t-shirts in there we're not um we're
using
red bub
bubble mm-hmm yes
yeah we're using that to ship because
they can go overseas because i have fans
in um
uk
australia down under mates
and all over the all over the world and
redbubble is the only one that can
worship overseas
how did you find your crew like i we
were marveling at not only do you have
the same director for a lot of the
videos but like
we are huge
get down goblin fans here
and so we were looking at the you know
the the girls that you have with you
dancing i'm not sure if they're the same
girls from mission to mars they look the
same to us
uh stay out yeah um
michelle
was doing nails and she had a nail shop
and romana also worked there and
her
sister-in-law
um
nikki
did my hair so
and i just asked them if they'd like to
be in a music video and they said yeah
so then that so then that's how i i got
them in in the music videos they were
just friends who choreographed that what
they're doing on the steps is pretty uh
it's such a they're good contemporary
moves uh did you call did you uh
um choreograph that no
no the the three girls um worked on it
themselves and they
they they invented it listening to the
music they
they just wanted to they said can we do
some dancing in it and i'm like yeah
sure now jen what did you do when you
were like younger before you did music
what was your like when you were a kid
and when you were what did you want to
do and what did you do before you you
obviously became a pop star
i'm not considered a pop star because
i'm i'm too normal
um no no there you go
well because i'm not i don't consider
myself like lady gaga
and those um
why entailment in them because um i i
talk i talk down the earth to to people
and that's true i do answer the the
the fan
mail and stuff like that so um
no as a kid i
did modeling
for um
a department store called weibos i was a
cute kid we don't know what happened
come on you're adorable
yeah and um
i love james bond movie i i wanted to be
like the first female james bond
um
yeah
yeah and um
that was about it i just mostly had a
normal type
childhood what made you what made you
take things into your own hands you know
there are a lot of people with a dream
to be a musician
but there are not a lot of people
who would
kind of take the ball themselves and go
you know what
i'm going to write some songs myself i'm
going to record these songs myself i'm
going to make these music videos right
like what was the thing that pushed you
to just do it yourself and as they say
get her done
well i looked into different studios see
how much they cost and when i was
working doing the limo
um i
saved money and
i just did it it just you know
it was just something i wanted to get
done and then i looked into um
uh who who gave me the best deal to do
um
get the cds
made and um
in the cassettes and that's about it wow
and then i i i went to those records and
i went around
trying to
get deals with them and and jim thompson
um
kept um giving it giving it to a lot of
um
the people in the music industry listen
and let's listen to this and then he
worked for towel records and we got into
title records and then i got this guy
dave and he got me in the best buy wow
but it was only as a local artist
the same as like towel records towel
recruited a local artist section which
is where now we've also seen i'm sorry
to interrupt you jen you did some uh
some tv stuff which i thought was great
i thought you on the news it was with
the uh the billowing smoke i thought
that was a great appearance i watched
your a couple of your news appearances
and some of your live stuff um have you
done any tv in the last couple of years
and uh if you haven't you certainly
should be
um the only thing i was on was hot
package
nice
yeah
yeah hot package and then um
a netflix um
called um
chicago
ant
chicago ant
a-u-n-t or a-n-t yeah a-u-n-t okay um
they used they used get down goblin and
song in one of their episodes that rules
and then i was in and then i was in um
jim cam
jim
cameron crowe's um
almost famous
aloha
oh you gotta you got a film roll out of
it
well it was just
um it's
it's when he blows up the satellite and
i mean up in the left-hand corner they
use a steel shot of it now skyrockets i
wanted to because that's the one you
know your songs get stuck in people's
heads like they really do like it's the
first thing i thought of when i woke up
this morning with skyrockets now
skyrockets to hell
no one sees that coming because
skyrockets you'd assume go to heaven
please walk us through that
well yeah skyrockets you do go go to
heaven but when i was writing the song
it was like skyrocketed to hell taking
your love for granted skyrocket to hell
putting your love to shame yeah it's
about a cheating boyfriend so what an
[ __ ] honestly yeah and you open up
you're you're online you're on the beach
um and again it's a little it's it's a
sexy look with the bikini
it was in malibu in um
it's that will rogers um
state park over there okay and let me
tell you that whole day
the water is freezing at 8 a.m in the
morning it is freezing
in the ocean
and then and then um
then
beverly hills my denny loved beverly
hills what a dog that was going to
beverly hills on his birthday we would
take him
um
to
get pink's hot dog
then
you're going to stop
cappuccino
then he
likes to walk around beverly hills rodeo
boat a lot and he loves cardenas
and then
we will like spend the whole day in
beverly hills
that's very yeah we're looking at you on
the rocks right now just kind of
pensively
glancing out at the ocean like something
has happened you really tell a story
when you do a video
well i majored in there at columbia
college in radio tv and film and um
so i had screenwriting in in
tv production and film and
um
you're doing the song and you try to get
the song close to the video yeah that
makes sense
what did you what did you do with
marilyn manson
um i opened well
he um
jim thompson gave him a promo of my
of my two albums and um
i should say two cds
and my um
i had um
the six music videos and he gave it to
that and
manson scared girlfriend rose mcgowan
they flew me out to perform for her uh
birthday party and then and then in
october he was coming out to chicago
and they and i opened up for him
that's amazing that's awesome how and
how was that experience
it was different
um
because i was the first very act to go
on
but uh rose mcgovern wasn't coming in
but um because she knew that i was
opening for him she flew in and and she
made the announcement and so
for his people oh that's to let them
know that you were there as kind of a
friend and as a
as a favor to him almost that's awesome
right she's a very she's a very nice uh
lady who's this i like
rose mcgovern is very nice oh that's
nice yeah i see some pictures of you
with with the two of them uh yeah that's
98 right that is the height of marilyn
manson's i mean
uh fame that where his face dope show
manson yes it is yeah it was
us
on the dope show beautiful people
beautiful people huh
i remember that yeah that was a big time
i was a fan would you cover dope show or
would you cover i i do you ever cover i
heard your ave maria which i thought was
almost in induced me to tears
uh reduced i was gonna say induced tears
and reduced me um i learned that when we
um when i was like
16 years old and my singing
teacher amperilla
from depaul university
um she said to me
because i said
because you you they only play their
song at like
funerals or weddings and things like
that right and i said it needs to be
spiced up and she goes dan like speak
like william shakespeare you don't
want masterpieces and then years later i
jazzed it up
nice what did you uh
what did you play at the manson show and
how did his fans react to you
i
only played five songs the songs that he
picked out were
losing you journey to mars
get down goblin
um
and i think rock and roll singing oh my
god
what a set amazing and i know skyrockets
was not out yet and irs was not out yet
of course of course late 90s i mean irs
no ios was out
what wait when it came out in 1994.
you didn't know that jim wait the album
i i heard it on another album though am
i crazy hold on a second now uh jen
let's she did irs in 94. ios was in it
was in high risk
and then i
and then under holiday songs i took ios
again and put it i added that to the
holiday songs you know what you're
absolutely of course you're right it's
your music i'm such an idiot i was
thinking that was one of the uh
one of the newer ones i love the uh the
high risk cover
it's you kind of you look almost like
you're ready to conquer you're on the
horse uh you're looking for that was my
husband everybody
wait the horse
this was my husband
yeah you look very comfortable on the
horse are you a competitive rider okay
no i i used to ride when i was younger
so oh i just wanted
i just i just wanted a picture with the
horse so that's very nice did you ever
get to talk to
the fella that you wrote losing you
about did you ever get to talk to him
again after the song came out great
question
uh no because it's
um it's just
to tell you the truth it's just a song
it's not about anybody it's just it's
just a song what oh it's just a general
song about love and love lost
what
you're very passionate uh have you had a
bunch of are you in a relationship or do
you date often or do you kind of like
being solo
uh i don't date that much but
um i date a little bit you have a lot of
passion
yep yeah i'm a target what do you expect
but then again you wrote a song about it
no no no what was the irish bible irish
eyes or something and you also speak
french
was it called my little brother or
something
yes um yeah i had french 101 in high
school oh no and um and the only thing
there wasn't really new irish songs out
so
um
technically what i was trying to do
and the people in the record industry
told me it's impossible i want to make
one album for every
a calendar for the whole for the whole
year like have something in january
february has every day is valentine's
day
march has irish eyes april has um
irs
ios then i need something for may
something for june may flowers
maybe showers may showers uh april
showers bring may flowers that's not
and the reason why i get down goblin is
because
after monster
after monster mashed
technically wasn't any
halloween songs i mean i don't consider
twiller
a halloween song
so
hey hey jan one question who's that
knocking at the door
well the waving never more
[Laughter]
yeah
ah
well by the way if people want to get
your books where can they order them and
where can people they can't bro well the
books they
because i have to hit i have to go
across the street to the printing place
and hand and
pay for them and get them and then then
i'll post them and then people will pay
through paypal for me
it'll be up oh okay you know what you
should do jan you should put out
pre-orders for them
if you put out pre-orders that way you
know exactly how many to print and it's
all
profit ski yeah
well yeah and then i understand the post
office is is um going up with the prices
uh you can raise that
let the customer absorb that leave it to
the government huh it's like the irs and
all the taxes
it's just like yep they leave you with a
hole in your pocket you know what i mean
well yeah yeah the more you have the
more they want that's a good point
so when i do the ending of the song i i
do the chicken thing well he goes ios
just change your pocket the ios just
want you so more you have the more they
want leave your heart a big big hole
i love it
i like the chicken thing a lot what's
your who are your biggest influences
because i hear a lot in the songs that
we've been listening to there's two
things i hear a lot of a lot of punk yep
you know a lot of joan jett almost and
then also there's quite a significant
like 80s hip-hop influence because you
do a lot of rap breaks there's a rap
break in uh irs there's a couple of
others i know that yeah that's another
thing in the country people hear of
[ __ ] fit they said there is no such
thing as yes
as weaponing in there but now but now
the new generation of country and
western has that it has it in yeah well
yeah i mean you're the you're you're the
forefront pioneer yeah
so who wh what it what what are your big
influences
i live the beatles
i got to see i got to see the beatles
live in
65 when they were here here in chicago
oh wow um elvis presley i liked a lot of
his music the king i like um some of
baba mandrell
um my voice was similar back in the
during high school
like olivia newton john i love olivia
newton john mcintyre physical um
i just have a mixture of a whole bunch
of things in songwriting i would say
some billy mantle music bacharach
the beatles have easy um
for the course which kind of like um
that's sort of like
my writing is with the course with you
know that
like love love me do and um
she's got a ticket to uh
you know they that some of that stuff's
sticking your head and and then chicago
um
with in uh casey and the sunshine
sure like i said
like i said
um mixtures of all different general
music and jen you also do a song too
called i want to remember the second
artist elvis presley and is it sammy
davis who's the one that you have them
singing together
yes um yeah because my dad was going to
my dad used to
dress up like elvis and
sometimes they're dressed up like sammy
davies jews it was called elvis and
sammy he was dressing like sammy did he
have his clothes how would he do that
he he had um
he had us
he had a suit and he
and he and he got um i helped him get
this makeup and he put that makeup on
and he went into a bar and they were
gonna throw him out because they didn't
know it was him oh no yeah no i get that
and he would do sammy
what yeah
yeah oh good for him
well back back in the um i think the
early 50s
sammy davis jr and his
uncles
um used to tap dance and they used to do
stuff at um
the boardwalk because my dad my dad has
originally from philadelphia in jersey
and there so he used to hang out there
well the song is very good
i mean it's item interruption
yeah whose friend was with um
freddy bell in the bellhops okay yeah
and i use we used to see him in las
vegas and in chicago
have you ever considered writing a
musical for the stage like like telling
a a narrative
through an entire album
um
like tommy
yes a rock maybe a rock opera i think
i've seen i seen that movie with ann
margaret and um
the guy from the who was in it and elton
john was in it i'm the pinball wizard
no that that will be kind of hard to do
so so that's it i mean
yeah are you up for collaboration with
other artists like if somebody uh wanted
to collaborate on a song with you you'd
do that right
yeah i'll think about it you know
yeah i think you should be doing more
stuff we we enjoy your your work very
much and uh i think you're very
underrated and i'm happy that people are
uh are finding you
well thank you very much yeah what kind
of thing you guys are doing this thing
for the whole week yes
it's jan terry week what kind of just
out of curiosity
what kind of what kind of money would it
set us back
to get like a a jan terry theme song
done for the show
not that much but um i could say i could
work on it and think about it yeah maybe
we could uh travis our producer could
talk to you about that off the air so
you don't want to give your private
finances out but we could easily throw
50 at you yeah well we'll see we can
maybe do a little more yeah
whatever jan requires
well thank you very much
we uh we love you jen very much uh we
think you're awesome and where can
people go to get your stuff where you're
actually going to see some of that money
well we go
web
bubble is um the merchandise thing also
i do autographs phone calls and video
messages i'm not on camera um
um
you order it through my
paypal or band camp why not cameo do you
want to be on
cameo people
cameo i understand takes a big chunk out
of your money and plus two
um when i tried um a
couple years ago to get on they wouldn't
let me on so i'm having my my um my
cousin's looking into to
see about getting me on we might be able
to we might be able to help you with
that i think we do yeah they do take a
cut of the money but i mean it is what
it is it's almost like you just talk
into the phone for a minute and then all
of a sudden you know you have a little
money in the bank it does i also i also
think you could charge more to make up
for what you're doing because of the
amount of eyes that would be on you
people would find you on cameo that way
you'd probably in in in the amount of
videos you would do you'd probably make
something you know double what you're
making now
even more but yeah i think jim and i
could probably help you sure with that
yeah but the only thing is i'm not like
your typical artist i don't like to whip
off the people i like to make it
affordable for people
so you know that's another that's
another big thing yeah of course
yeah yeah i don't think charging 300 to
thousands of dollars to see people in
concerts
and things i mean it's not right no
so it because it's more for the music
it's more to make people happy to forget
about the problems to um
for the
hour that you're on stage
people can can
go someplace and you know just have fun
forget their troubles yeah
yeah
well jan thank you so much uh we're fans
and we're happy we got to talk to you
we'll talk to you again of course uh and
travis will keep in touch with you about
projects and any way that we can help uh
you know get your name out there anytime
yeah and anytime you guys need me on the
show you want to talk just you know
where are you located are you still in
chicago are you out in hollywood
i'm in uh lake elsinore i'm in
california oh you are okay great you're
enjoying the nice weather um we'll talk
to you again okay it's a little cold out
here but oh is it cold okay
well i missed the food out in new york
yeah the food here is good
i mix my pizza i miss my
um
my hot dog
well i tell you what you can whenever
you're traveling again whenever you find
yourself in new york you have a space
right here in the studio
do a little singing do a little talking
whatever you want to do you're always
welcome here yep
okay thanks guys thank you very much the
great jan terry thank you for coming on
john it's great talking to you
you